now many of the millions of refugees who
have fled the war in ukraine are not
ukrainian nationals some are students
from other parts of the world and some
of them say they have faced racism and
discrimination as they try to flee the
fighting
wisdom edward has lost his old way of
life
the nigerian was studying in kharkiv
ukraine
then the war came and he fled to germany
what i've worked for what i've
gotten and
the stability i thought i had just went
away
in one day
wisdom found a home with a german couple
but it's unlikely that he will be
allowed to stay
all ukrainians get residential rights
but people from africa or other
countries who have lived or studied in
ukraine are denied this right this is a
great injustice
ukrainian citizens can stay and work in
germany for at least a year
that's not the case for everyone fleeing
the war wisdom might be sent back to his
native nigeria
i worked really hard to save up money
to go studying in ukraine and now the
hopes of my future is just gone i might
be safe
physically now here in cologne but
mentally i'm not safe
because i have this
reoccurrence of what next
wisdom tries to keep himself busy
he's joined an organization that helps
african students in the same situation
wisdom and the other african students
hope they can stay
i wish the
german government could create
opportunities because we all face the
same issue the same war the same tragic
situation the bullets and the bomb
doesn't know
nationalities and doesn't know skin
color